George Michael's cause of death has been  revealed Ichi can't confirm the iconic  singer died of natural causes a coroner  has ruled after Michael's tragic death  on Christmas Day in 2016  The Times Valley Police Department  deemed the legendary musicians autopsy  was inconclusive  authorities said in a statement obtained  by ET the investigation has now  concluded and no further action is  proposed or required Michael's boyfriend  body follows who found the singer dead  broke his silence after the autopsy  results writing all the nasty comments  were very cruel and unnecessary now I  hope to receive some real love since his  passing fans and stars have paid their  respects to the late pop singer with  touching tributes Adele took to the  stage at the 2017 Grammys and delivered  an emotional cover of his hit fast love  [Music]